[Music]
welcome to powis castle and gardens
once home to a welsh prince
now home to the biggest hedges in the uk
they're around 400 years old
and it's this guy's job to cut them my
name's danville and i'm a gardener here
at paris castle and gardens
the large hedges were planted in the
18th century the fashion change in the
victorian era and that's the unique
shape we have today
we have 14 large temps on the terraces
and a big hedge that's approximately
eight thousand square meters of hedging
the box hedges and the formal hedging is
about seven thousand square meters so in
total we have fifteen thousand square
meters of hedges to cut
and one being 55 feet tall for anyone
who doesn't like kites
might be best you look away now
one of the highlights for me is when we
get the cherry pickers in
and spending the time floating around
the sky looking at the wildlife and
cutting the hedges fortunately i quite
light height so it's lovely being up
there
back in the day it took ten men four
months to trim all the hedges tying
ladders together and using hand shears
nowadays dan is able to complete the
mammoth task in just eight weeks
with mechanization we've been able to
use electric and petrol hedge cutters
long reach hedge cutters it's a lot
better than trying to do it with a side
along with the hedges dan is among the
seven gardeners who work throughout the
year come rain or shine to manage the
ever-evolving grounds i do a bit of
everything rather than being just stuck
in one part of the garden i've been here
for 12 years i love coming to work i'm
quite lucky in my role i get here early
most mornings and take my dog round the
garden so it's lovely i'll be here at
seven o'clock in the morning the mists
rising and you're just looking over at
the castle in the garden and feel quite
privileged to be working here
[Music]
you